plastic is one of the planet's most
pressing environmental problems 90% of
the plastic we use ends up in landfills
or in the world's oceans now a firm has
invented a way to retool that hard to
use plastic for a role that requires
durability paving roads and highways
Roxana Saberi paid them a visit so this
looks like regular asphalt yeah but it's
not
sounds like grass blade made of recycled
plastic that's right the driveway at
Christopher Boyles 17th century English
state is paved with 21st century plastic
trash it has all the ecological and
environmental benefits but to ordinary
punter you didn't see any difference at
all the difference is that it used the
equivalent of 750,000 plastic bags and
bottles ground up along with other hard
to recycle plastic this is our Cheetos
bags our bottle tops you name it the
plastic flakes are mixed at this plant
in Scotland with what Toby McCartney
calls a secret ingredient pack it up and
then off it goes to the asphalt
manufacturers that blend replaces some
of the black oil-based bitumen that
keeps regular roads together for every
tonne of bitumen that we replace we save
a ton of carbon emissions so for the
environment it's it's the way forward
Courtney says it's the best way to
tackle the world's plastic waste 90% of
which ends up as litter and landfill now
his company macgruber is paving plastic
roads across the world from highways in
England to this street in San Diego
where the firm is also opening a new
factory so is this a long-term solution
to the world's plastic problem I believe
so is the stuff that nobody else can use
is destined for landfill or for
incineration we can take all of that
plastic and we can recycle it in our
roads environmentalists like Libby peek
are cautiously optimistic they're
potentially lower carbon than
conventional roads so that's very
positive what we don't know yet
how much microplastics these roads might
shed there are no microplastics present
in any of the roads that go down but
shouldn't people just stop using plastic
I don't know whether that's ever really
going to happen McCartney says for now
plastic pavement can curb the world's
plastic epidemic a sentiment shared by
Boyle who says since he laid down his
plastic driveway three years ago it's
held up fine why do you think more
places haven't paved their roads with
plastic yet I'm not sure that very many
people know about the technology at all
you think they should definitely for CBS
this morning Saturday Roxana Saberi
Lockerbie Scotland and now they do they
didn't know about it you can't do it
yeah and people probably will keep using
plastic not everybody's going to stop
yeah I'm having a hard time
understanding whether or not micro
plastics are inside those roads so
that's the big question if the paper
straws there right now yes these are
paper paper don't even falling apart
don't go there we have this Jeff